earn me let's mark this old me's what is
good how you livin I am not in the
studio if you're listening on audio it
really doesn't matter but if you hear
noises like that of a drone it's because
we are in LA you're here at Rams camp
and that new show that I keep talking to
you guys about the premium show on
YouTube we're cracking out some episodes
I got Inger on the road he looks like a
young who's the rent Ron Howard right
now it's really nice he's got a hat all
with the headphones but I told you guys
that after hard knocks I would tell you
if it's still alive or if it's dead I'll
have that verdict for you in a few
minutes you got to stick through some
content first first I just want to say I
talked to the man ezel 91 fantasy
leagues have already been created you
guys are crazy
91 I think we finished around 99 or 97
but if you haven't responded to the
email yet do that but shout out to the
homie ezel for holding that all down
also next week I'm gonna be in Vegas and
so we're gonna have an episode that's
gonna come out next week where I'm gonna
make some bets with crack all you know
the crack is and we're going to I'm
gonna make some like season-long bets
and so if you guys want to bet with me
more than willing to but I'm gonna take
all the tickets I'm gonna bring them
back to the studio and we're gonna hang
them up so we can follow my bets all
year round because if I'm making money
you're making money for sure but we're
here in Rams camp and it actually worked
out perfectly because the Rams if you
guys saw played the Raiders on that
episode of hard knocks
and before I get to my verdict I want to
give you some of the things that I liked
from the episode because I want to go
positive oh we hear the Tron everything
looks good in drones by the way I don't
know if I'm supposed to do this yet but
the name of the show I can do this I'm
doing it the name of the show is gonna
be called ditch the PlayBook with Lefko
because when we do a show whatever you
think you're gonna do everything you're
gonna see I want you to take that book
I want you to rip it down the seam I
want you to throw into the trash because
we're ditching it and I'm no longer
going by Adam left go I want to be
Prince I want to be Madonna I want to be
Michael left go that's it
putting the whole family on my back
we're going for generations to come but
it's gonna be ditch the PlayBook with
Lefko I'm not giving you any more
details there's gonna be articles coming
out soon if people like getting excited
whether it's like awful announcing or
sports business journal you'll read all
about it but the reason we're able to do
all this stuff is because of you guys
the 33% and I appreciate you now to Hard
Knocks things I liked
Hunter Renfro is adorable and he's
nervous and he makes me laugh he gets up
there and he sings lean on me and he's
got the receding hairline and I know all
about that but hunter you're a baby and
I love it
he was nervous to propose to his fiancee
but I think the quote that sums up
hunter Renfro I'm gonna block the wind
here as we're in a wind tunnel here in
LA the line that summed up hunter Renfro
one line was when he looked at Keele and
das on the sidelines and said sometimes
God just winks at you that is hunter
Renfro in a nutshell he is so innocent
and I do think the fact that we can go
from Antonio Brown with all the ego and
the craziness and the guy that's gonna
be replacing them is balding hunter
Renfro is one the perfect dichotomy
switches that I've ever seen I loved the
Gruden McVeigh pissed boy the fact that
we got to see like 16 year-old Shawn
McVeigh and guru and say when I was
young I was the piss boy and then we
called Shawn McVeigh the piss boy I love
that and then I also love the fact that
Gruden until the end of time is gonna
take credit for Shawn McVeigh because
that's just a very Gruden thing to do my
favorite Gruden lines from the episode
Gruden says to Mike Glennon you're so
casual like a house Mouse the [ __ ] does
that mean like I always like I don't
know if Gruden is secretly like an 85
year old man and has like these stories
that I'm like he also had another one
which I thought was great which was my
life is running out of life span and
Ingeborg hit me up and he goes I think
he got in
RuPt it and like didn't know what to say
he's like you're making my life it's
running out of lifespan Gruden's a nut
job I also like number three he said be
a little bit more like me be a jerk and
anyone that openly he also called
himself a dick in the episode I love the
fact that guru Dan like appreciates that
he knows he's a dick and then he knows
he's a jerk and he's telling Glennon and
Nathan Peterman he destroyed those guys
I mean he called Peterman a blockhead
Glenn and he goes what are you doing
what are you doing what do you do it and
and this is from all the times that we
did shows with Sims and he would hear
him riding Sims the fact that Gruden
treats everybody like crap which is I
secretly think he doesn't like Derek
Carr I really believe that and I know
that Derek Carr bought a house next to
him but like Derek Carr will come over
there and be like I just didn't see it
and Gruden never talks he never talks
but to Peterman and to Glen and he's
always coaching but I think my favorite
moment though of Gruden was when he sits
standing there from the team and he goes
alright week two everybody do the
handshakes okay and he goes what we need
this week guys is is we need better
execution we need better execute like he
turned the switch up like it was nothing
and that's crude and like can't you see
Gruden at a dinner table be like please
pass the rolls can you pass the [ __ ]
rolls there's just the fact that Gruden
could just turn it up at any time I
[ __ ] love it so we got more Gruden I
loved that I loved Hunter Renfro I loved
that we got more great moments at
Jonathan Abram at the end of the episode
saying Tom Brady could have been my
daddy talking about Aaron down all that
the fact that he looked at charles
woodson Ingeborg and said i'm just
trying to get 1% better every day
Jonathan Abram listens to the podcast
that's all that it means he's officially
a part of the 33% he's stealing my lines
about getting better 1% every day and
he's going to Charles woods and we're in
the same jersey number that he didn't go
I'm just trying to get 1% and Charles
once he goes oh I love that
so now Charles Woodson is practically a
member the 33 percent - so that's what
it means
few other news and notes before I get to
whether this show is
life one Cleveland Farrell's averages
[ __ ] and I'm just gonna come out and say
it I know he went forth picking the
draft and I know that they're gonna sell
you one leadership but homeys what did
we learn if you're gonna tell me that a
rookie is a good leader and Goods good
effort you know what that doesn't mean
he's a [ __ ] animal and that he's a
freak and he's athletic you've heard
them describing an errand Donald man his
feet are so fast he's so strong he moves
like a DB you know what they didn't say
man he's got good energy out there or
Aaron Donald seems like a nice guy
I watched Cleland feral you guys watch
Cleveland feral i watch the preseason
game too
he's gonna be that guy that's in the NFL
for a long time he's gonna be good but
he's not the fourth pick in the draft
and the Raiders [ __ ] up and I'm okay
saying that and I'm sorry Raiders fans
but I just want Raiders fans to know
that as I critiqued the show and as I
critique Antonio Brown I am rooting for
the Raiders to make the playoffs Jon
Gruden making the playoffs is better for
all of us the Raiders making the
playoffs is where this league needs to
be I'm rooting for Derek Carr do I find
him annoying yes like I find Carson
Wentz knowing sometimes and that's my
quarterback so I don't really care so
all the Raiders fans in my mentions
talking about how I'm hating on the
Raiders I'm not hating on the Raiders
but stop being a fanboy and know that
it's okay for your quarter but your
quarterback is kind of a dork Derek Carr
is kind of a dork
all right embrace it all writing bear
I'm ready to get to him number one I
haven't seen Josh Jacobs once number two
I haven't seen Mark Davis really do
anything other than shake hands at a
picnic I haven't seen Tyrell Williams I
haven't seen Trent Brown we have a lot
of holes but I said coming into this
episode that we needed to see behind the
scenes of the a be saga and I'm telling
you in that episode start I thought holy
[ __ ] were going to the next stratosphere
where do we go almost right away on a
field Antonio Brown takes his shoes off
showing his feet drop in lines like my
feet are circumsized he gave us all the
details
first of all savage line my feet are
circumcised he said that when it was
flopping out it looked like a whoopee
cushion
he even gave the details that he was in
Paris and that he had to do cold therapy
and he swelled up and he couldn't walk
and they're draining it and using a
scalpel and the knife and I'm sitting
there in this hotel room in Thousand
Oaks is that where we are
Thousand Oaks going they're gonna give
us all the goods
isn't that right drone drone agrees I'm
going we're seeing it we're seeing how
it is they're talking about it they go
right to camp and John Gruden's at camp
and he's just like how long is this
gonna be these burns are serious and I'm
going this is it and then the show
[ __ ] died and I stand here before you
today ready to read a eulogy because the
Hard Knocks is you know it does not
matter anymore and it has deceased how
did they break into the two news events
about a Antonio Brown helmet and feet
clips of NFL Network state TV and then
what happened
nothing nothing we got nothing from the
players we got nothing from Antonio
Brown [ __ ] dude even in the way they
promoted the next episode they said they
showed a clip from NFL Network News
breaking in about him losing the
arbitration and then something from
Instagram what has happened to hard
knocks to expound upon this a little bit
more the only nugget we got was when Jon
Gruden was in the coaching meet and he
looked around he said has anyone seen my
friend Antonio everything else was
things we've already seen a press
conference where he stands by Antonio
Brown
he tells Brent Musburger I don't want to
talk about it I don't want to talk about
it and if that's hard-knocks way of
saying that they weren't gonna talk
about it with us either that's fine let
me ask you a question have we seen one
camera angle inside john gruben's office
other than that two second clip of
McVeigh no have we been in mike Mayock
office no have we been in the wide
reciever room no so I want to say that I
had this theory this morning and I said
it to Ingrid that I really think
hard-knocks knew they had to get the
Raiders and it sounds like they may have
made concerns
in order to make this happen I'm just
letting you know with a story that has
dominated the news cycle for a week
Antonio Brown is the number one click
getter in the entire sports ecosystem
right now and all I get is two clips
from NFL Network in Instagram post and
Jon Gruden saying have you seen my
friend Antonio is dead so let me say
this here
dearly beloved as we gather here today
we stand on top of a giant feet whose
shoes will likely never be filled and
not because of cryotherapy hard knocks
brought us joy it brought us things like
bamm-bamm chicken and shrimp it brought
us things like kiss the baby and child
please but today I stand here before you
putting it to rest Hard Knocks you've
had an incredible run and I am so sorry
to all the amazing producers and
everyone that works on this show that's
gonna watch this and go [ __ ] that guy
I'm just letting you know I [ __ ]
don't want to be saying this [ __ ] either
but hard knocks is dead r.i.p it was I
know that David liked it in burr because
I think that it had good football
moments but the fact that they spent the
episode focusing on Nathan Peterman and
kealan Doss instead of Antonio Brown you
needed to abandon all of these [ __ ]
storylines nobody cares if killin das is
playing in front of his hometown nobody
cares if Nathan Peterman they put Nathan
Peterman's 50 yard run got the Hard
Knocks treatment that Antonio Brown
should have gotten slow-motion with NFL
Films background music and an insight
from everybody and all I got from
Antonio Brown was an NFL new network
news hit so I stand here before you a
broken man a shattered man an upset man
and more importantly a disappointed man
okay so we're gonna be shooting with
some Rams players for the show ditch the
PlayBook with left OH
and the hashtag for the show is going to
be D the P so as these episodes come out
during the season make sure to use the
hashtag D the P be it me or anger came
out with that you can probably guess it
but love you guys so much Ingeborg
smiling right now cuz he's happy about
everything 33% you guys are the [ __ ] if
you haven't responded yet to the fantasy
leagues
we have over 91 filled out make sure you
get in there I'm gonna be in Vegas next
week
a lot more details to come and I'm
hoping to let you guys know about
co-hosts suits it's not official I don't
want to give it away I want to be a
really big surprise but I want you to
know that I came into this season
thinking one thing how can I create a
show and it's a 33 percent listens the
three days a week that they're gonna get
enough information to help them talk
football with their friends enough
information to make them better gamblers
and then also have some funny-ass [ __ ]
happen that it's gonna be great and I'm
letting you know that I have found some
guys but I think it's gonna be amazing
so we're really close to announcing it
but just let you know that we're getting
1% better every day
and I really think with these guys we
might be going up 10% so buckle the [ __ ]
up get [ __ ] excited I'm gonna stop
cursing cuz YouTube might pull this
video but I love you guys a lot holla
holla holla Jake
editing back in the end headquarters I
appreciate you to all the crew me come
on come here really quick so audio
dude's been holding this the whole time
[Music]
perfect see you guys
[Music]